peace be with you I said I'm alaykoum I
wanted to spend just a few minutes with
you on someone I thought was very very
important most of you know by now the
anti Islam the protests they happen in
Arizona
now they've coming together to have some
more with the guns outside of places of
worship disrupting people's peace we're
not going to get into the double
standard here if this was done in front
of the churches or synagogues Muslims
going and protesting with guns how this
would be betrayed but I was really
flabbergasted to see how the Creator
works look because it is incumbent on
all of us to love for Humanity what we
love for ourselves Islam is L AM says
love all mankind and we truly care
that's why we're supposed to share but
we have been sharing okay
we failed there now since we didn't go
out and share the creator of the heavens
and earth is bringing them to our doors
I would just amazed at this golden
opportunity that look you didn't get it
we didn't get out there so now Allah the
Creator the Almighty is bringing the
people to us so what are we gonna do
with it
what are we gonna do so I got some
things that I think are good points that
you can go ahead is in a community a
come together and have a nice meeting to
discuss this and you can add to this
also but you got to open the doors now I
know mosques are always open to people
but have this day designated that you
have an open house that people can come
in and see that the musters aren't
bomb-making factories and it's not a
place just smells like biryani and
carrot curry no they can really come in
and they can have a tour of the mosque
they can be explained a simple message
of Islam the pure monotheism of Islam
the universal message of Islam the
Brotherhood and sisterhood of Islam the
way of life that was lived by Jesus's
Abraham no one all the prophets that God
Almighty sent he sent them witness Lomb
submission to the will of the creator
not the creation this is Islam it
resonates with the heart the natural fit
though the inclination the that God
Almighty put in all of us but now that
it's been distorted people have gotten
to wrong perception because the wrong
message has been delivered to man or no
messages all except what Fox News and
all these other media
outlets are feeding to them so that's
the first thing open the doors open
house to have the food ready get some
pizza get some water
you got guests and Islam we're told to
honor our guests these are guests who
are coming to visit you so now you
better have a smile it doesn't matter
what hate rhetoric they spew at you you
say words of peace that's it you don't
return this hateful rhetoric with
hateful rhetoric no it's not gonna work
so have the food ready three big huge
banners representing some of the
teachings of Islam brochure is set up at
tables so people can go ahead and freely
take it they can pick up a Quran read it
it's an open book they can go ahead
proShares on on Jesus on the Quran and
the scientific miracles in the Quran the
evidence that we have that proves that
Islam is indeed a way of life from the
crater have this all ready to go and
another thing that's an extremely
important have a good spokesperson on
the front to be able to communicate to
the people
somebody preferably you have so many
now's the time for the people to reverse
the converse to step up dressed to
impress so Islam is not looked at as the
other you can be a Italian Muslim an
Irish Muslim you can be a Muslim
American Muslim Muslims like Jesus was
Jesus was one who submitted told him God
well that's what a Muslim is so I have
them dressed to impress speaking the
clear simple English and communicate
this message this message of peace peace
acquired by what submission to the will
of God talk about the similarities the
crater worshiping him alone not his
Christian you know Mary the deep love
that we have for Jesus his mother and we
call upon the crater the one that she
called upon cuz she when she had Jesus
in her womb she wasn't calling upon him
she was calling upon the one who put
Jesus in her womb that's the same God
that we call upon then Jesus came out of
the womb and he called upon who the
create or that's the one that we worship
the one who sent Islam
is a mercy to humanity and the last and
final mission problem Hamid peace be
upon him all of these things are so
simple and so clear and they resonate
it's something that it's their right to
know and at the end doesn't matter what
happens they accept or reject your duty
is just to share and be the best host
give these people some love it's your
chance now Allah is sending them to you
he's sending them at your front door I'm
just I'm so amazed by this this is this
is just amazing what an opportunity I'm
excited I wish I can be with everyone at
every one of these these musters when
the people are there but I can't but I
can share with you like I've done some
of the things that you can be doing you
can add some things that you think will
be effective but do your part now do
something don't just run on a bus do the
right thing give these people some love
Kim some love and tune in every week to
the D show send them to the Deen show
don't forget we also have a 1-800 number
1 862 Islam have them tune into Deen
show calm and we'll see you every week
new show until then peace be with you
Islamic